[Music]
samandar you are a very busy fellow
you've got a lot of movies going on here
right yeah yeah you may not as the
measuring stick exactly who can make it
here has got to be busy you just is it
my right you just finished shooting a
movie where you play John F Kennedy I
did yes
which is easy yeah I would say probably
one of the hardest people to play I
think because it's such an iconic look
but also the accent so specific and
almost I would think impossible to do
yes virtually impossible you're from
Boston very well know the accent but
whenever I do it it's really me doing
mayor Quimby from The Simpsons
oh my Simpson yeah that that is good I
can get in there a little bit but if
you're really trying to portray him
accurately what was the technique that
you use I would go to sleep listening to
the the podcasts of his speeches so I
you know it's so that was helpful
what about what are the most difficult
words or the words that I had a tough
time with hemisphere
the world hemisphere he would use thanks
for allies I'm saying hemisphere he'd
say hemisphere mm-hmm it was a diphthong
there I guess is what that's called I
had to deliver some of his speeches
which was pretty cool
so you know it's a daunting thing
stepping into those shoes obviously but
it's it's not a movie about two john f
kennedy's it's so I'm okay yeah well
three or four days of work it was it's
it's a movie that it's called the Butler
said Butler yeah the account of the
butler who served at the White House
over eight presidencies and all the
presidencies all the presidents are sort
of peripheral characters but it's his
account through Ike and Robin Williams
plays like big cast Oprah Winfrey's in
the movie Robin Williams plays
Eisenhower plays Eisenhower yeah we all
have lots of prosthetics on and wigs
obviously you're kidding no Robin
Williams plays Eisenhower yeah Oh trust
back oh he's just like you know
he hasn't said Shahs BOTS in 50 years
that's my coach for Robin Williams miss
who met Oprah is in the movie she's our
big star I've heard of her
yeah wonderful she plays Jimmy Carter
[Applause]
yes wonderful woman met her when she was
doing her camera tests came over gave me
a hug that's nice smelled wonderful she
wouldn't tell us what Oprah smells like
she smelled like diamonds
[Laughter]